- Welcome back to Understanding
Quantum Information and Computation.
My name is John Watrous, and
I'm the Technical Director for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the fourth lesson of the series and it's the final
lesson in the first unit of the series on the basics
of quantum information.
Thus far, we've talked about
how quantum information works for both single and multiple systems, we've taken a look at the
quantum circuit model,
and we've observed some
fundamental limitations on quantum information.
Along the way, we
encountered some important mathematical concepts
including tensor products and inner products, and we'll continue
to make use of those concepts and we'll introduce some new
ones as well as we need them.
In this lesson, we'll be
focusing on three fundamental important examples, quantum teleportation, superdense coding and the CHSH game,
which is also called the CHSH inequality and not always described as a game.
These are not just random
examples meant to illustrate how quantum information works, they really are key
parts of the foundation
of quantum information and
they arise in different and sometimes unexpected settings within quantum information
and computation.
Entanglement plays a key role in all three of these
examples, and in fact, it's entanglement that makes them work
and makes them interesting. So, this lesson will, in some sense, be our first opportunity to
see entanglement in action
and to begin to explore what it is that makes entanglement so interesting.
The overview for the
lesson is very simple, we'll go one by one
through the three examples that I just mentioned,
quantum teleportation,
superdense coding, and the CHSH game.
We'll discuss what these things are and what makes them interesting and we'll go through analyses that explain exactly how they work
at a mathematical level.
Before we get to the first
of the three examples, which is quantum teleportation, it's appropriate to first
introduce the characters,
Alice and Bob, in case you're
not familiar with them.
Alice and and Bob, are names
given to hypothetical entities or agents in systems, protocols, games,
and really any other type of interaction you might wish to consider that involves the exchange of information.
They first arose in the
context of cryptography in the 1970s, but the
convention to use these names in this way has become very common
in a much broader context since then. The idea is that these
are very common names, at least in some parts of the world, and they start with the letters A and B,
and it's also convenient
to refer to Alice and Bob using the pronouns, her and him just for the sake of brevity.
We typically imagine that Alice and Bob are in different locations and that they have different
goals and different behaviors
depending upon whatever it is that we're talking about.
For example, if we're
talking about communication, meaning, the transmission of information, then we might decide
that Alice is the sender
and Bob is the receiver
of whatever information is being transmitted.
Sometimes Alice and Bob
cooperate, that's very typical, but sometimes they
compete or they might have different goals that may
or may not be consistent
with one another, but this
all has to be made clear in the situation at hand.
Of course, they represent abstractions and not necessarily actual human beings.
We can also introduce
additional characters such as Charlie and
Diane or different names that represent different
personas such as Eve
for an Eves Strapper or Mallory for someone behaving maliciously
depending upon the setting.
In any case, we will see Alice and Bob in all three of the
examples that we'll discuss in this lesson and from time to time
throughout the remainder of the series. I'll also make a few
comments about entanglement before moving on to the three examples.
In lesson two, we encounter this example of an entangled state of two Qubits.
It's one of the four bell states, and you could say that
this particular state represents the archetypal example
of an entangled quantum state.
We also encountered this
example of a probabilistic state of two bits.
It's analogous to the
entangled state in some sense, but it's not entangled,
entanglement is a uniquely
quantum phenomenon,
essentially by definition.
There is a precise mathematical definition of what entanglement is and basically what that definition
says is that entanglement
is a non-classical quantum correlation.
But that's not all that
helpful at an intuitive level, it's a definition of entanglement in terms of what entanglement isn't,
and it's probably for that
reason that it's sexually pretty difficult to explain what entanglement is and what makes it special
in intuitive terms.
When people do try to
explain what entanglement is in intuitive terms, you
often hear explanations that really don't
distinguish these two states
in a meaningful way. You may hear the idea
that if you measure one of the two entangled Qubits,
then the state of the other one
is somehow instantaneously affected or that the state of the two Qubits can't be described separately
or that the two Qubits
somehow maintain a memory of one another or even that
they're emotionally attached in some way.
But why are those properties
not true for this state?
These two bits are intimately connected, each one has a perfect
memory of the other one in a literal sense, but
it's not an entangled state.
Well, one way to explain what
makes entanglement special and what makes this state
very different from this state is to explain what we
can do with entanglement
or what we can see happening
because of entanglement that goes beyond the decisions we make about how we represent our
knowledge using vectors.
All three of the examples
that we'll discuss in this lesson have this nature in that they illustrate
things that we can do with entanglement that we
cannot do with this state
or with any classically correlated state.
Indeed, it's very typical in the study of quantum information and computation that we view entanglement as a resource
through which different
tasks can be accomplished.
And when we do that, we view this state as representing
one unit of entanglement.
We refer to this unit of
entanglement as an e-bit, the e stands for
entangled or entanglement.
It's true that it's two Qubits, but as a quantity of
entanglement, it's one e-bit.
You can also view a pair
of ordinary classical bits in the correlated
probabilistic state from before as being a resource which is
one bit of shared randomness.
It can be very useful in
cryptography to share a random bit with somebody presuming
that nobody else knows what that bit is so that it
can be used as a private key
or as part of a private key, for example, for the sake of encryption.
But in this lesson, our focus will be on this entangled state and
things that we can do with it.
And just to clarify the terminology, when we say that Alice
and Bob share an e-bit, what we mean is that
Alice has a qubit named A,
Bob has a qubit named B, and together the pair A, B
is in the Phi plus state.
It's not important what names
we choose for the two Qubits, of course, we could
choose different names, but throughout this lesson,
we'll stick with these names
in the interest of clarity. The first example of the lesson
is quantum teleportation,
which hereafter we'll just
refer to as teleportation for the sake of brevity.
What teleportation is is a protocol that allows a sender to
transmit quantum information to a receiver using only entanglement
and classical communication to
accomplish that transmission.
It has absolutely nothing to do with the typical interpretation
of the word teleportation in science fiction, which
is that matter disappears
at one location and appears in another.
Quantum teleportation is just a name that's meant to conjure that as an image or as a metaphor so to speak.
What's getting teleported is
quantum information not matter, and that's happening
through a transmission of classical information
together with entanglement.
To understand exactly
how teleportation works, it's helpful to begin by
setting the stage, so to speak.
What we'll do is to imagine a scenario involving Alice and Bob and
that scenario is as follows,
Alice has a qubit named Q that
she would like to transmit to Bob, meaning that she
wants Bob to hold in his hands
a qubit that's in exactly
the same state that Q is in as they begin the protocol.
In other words, we're talking about the fundamental problem of
information transmission or communication.
We have a sender named Alice
and a receiver named Bob and Alice wants to send
quantum information in the form of a qubit to Bob.
There is a constraint, however, which is that Alice is not
able to physically send Q to Bob, all that she can do is to send classical information to Bob.
Alice and Bob also have
an additional resource, which is that they share an e-bit.
So that's the scenario, it's
easy to imagine situations where the constraint that
Alice can't physically send Q
to Bob is a reasonable abstraction.
If Alice and Bob were on
different continents for instance, or if Alice didn't know
Bob's exact location, then physically sending a qubit
would probably be pretty challenging.
But classical communication
is of course not only possible but quite inexpensive
under those circumstances.
Now, one might ask whether it's possible for Alice and Bob to accomplish this task without even needing the shared e-bit.
In other words, is there
any way to transmit a qubit using classical
communication alone?
The answer is no, it's not possible to transmit quantum information using classical communication alone, and that's not too difficult to prove
using some basic quantum
information theory, which we'll see in the
third unit of the series.
For now, an intuitive
way to think about it is to think about the no-cloning theorem.
Imagine that there was a way
to send quantum information using classical communication alone,
but classical communication
can easily be copied and broadcast, so that means
the classical communication
could be broadcast to two
receivers, Bob and Charlie, let's say.
If they both received the
same classical information from Alice, then would
they both end up with Q?
That would suggest that we cloned Q, but we know that that's impossible.
Just as an aside, let's
observe that it certainly is possible to describe
quantum state vectors using classical information.
Every quantum state vector
you'll see in the series is being described to you
using classical information that was transmitted to whatever
device you're watching on.
In general, we could imagine
describing whatever state Q is in using classical bits
perhaps to some precision,
but that's not quantum communication, that's just describing
quantum states as vectors, and we'll come back to the
distinction between them
in just a moment.
Getting back to the scenario however, and working under the
assumption that Alice and Bob do share an e-bit, we will
see that Alice and Bob
have everything they need
to accomplish the task, and that's what the quantum
teleportation protocol does, specifically using two bits
of classical communication.
before getting into
these details, however, let me make a few quick
remarks just to make sure that the assumptions are clear.
First, we're assuming
here that the state of Q is unknown to Alice and
Bob, so in particular,
Alice can't send Bob a
description of the state Q because she doesn't know it in general.
We also have to consider the possibility that Q is correlated with other systems, including the possibility
that it's entangled
with other systems and the
transmission of this qubit to Bob must preserve those correlations.
Finally, I mentioned
the no-cloning theorem when I was talking about
trying to communicate Qubits classically, but
there's another connection here
with the no-cloning theorem, which is that if Bob
receives the transmission of this qubit Q from Alice,
then she must not have it anymore
because Q can't be cloned, and that's just something to keep in mind
as we consider the teleportation protocol.
The teleportation
protocol can be described in a pretty simple and direct way with the quantum circuit diagram as you can see right here.
It's slightly stylized in
that it depicts the separation between Alice's part and Bob's part, but otherwise, it's just
a quantum circuit diagram,
everything above the dotted
line represents Alice's actions and everything below
represents Bob's actions.
Time goes from left to right as always, and we see that we start
with these two Qubits here being in a Phi plus state,
so this is the e-bit
that Alice and Bob start with.
We can put labels on the Qubits to make clear which one is
which, so this is the qubit A, and this is the qubit
B that form the e-bit,
and this is the qubit Q that
Alice wishes to transmit to Bob.
Here we're hypothesizing that
the state of this qubit Q is Psi, but a little bit later on we'll consider the possibility
that Q is entangled
with some other system. And what the diagram is claiming because we've written psi down here,
is that this circuit
effectively does transmit whatever state psi we had
up here on Alice's part down here to Bob's part,
the only communication
that we have crossing the
line between Alice and Bob is the two classical
bits that are represented by these double lines right here.
Let's shrink this
diagram down a little bit so that we have a little bit more room and let's examine the
circuit more closely.
I've already described
the initial conditions, but just to recapitulate, Alice holds a qubit A
and Bob holds a qubit B,
where A and B together
are in a Phi plus state, so that's what it means to share an e-bit.
Alice also has this qubit Q that she wishes to transmit to Bob, and we're considering the case that Q is in some arbitrary quantum state Psi.
Now, we don't know anything
about how Alice and Bob came into possession of this e-bit.
It could be that they've
had it for a long time, maybe they created it some time ago when they were in the same location
and they've been saving
it for this occasion, but those details aren't relevant here.
The steps that happen next, which represent the
teleportation protocol itself are as follows, and just to be clear,
these are the steps that
the diagram describes and we're just gonna
write them down in words so that it's clear what
the diagram expresses.
Alice first performs a
controlled-NOT operation where the qubit Q that
she wants to send to Bob is the control and the
qubit A is the target.
The next step is that she
performs a Hadamard operation on Q, and then she measures
the two Qubits that she holds,
A and Q with respect to
standard basis measurements and we let lowercase a be the outcome of the measurement of the qubit A,
and we let lowercase b be the outcome of the measurement of the qubit Q.
Alice then sends those
two classical bits to Bob and this is the only communication that's involved in this protocol and that's indicated in the diagram
by the fact that these two
bits cross the dotted line between Alice and Bob,
which you can think of as representing whatever
distance separates them.
After Bob receives the bits
a and b, he does two things.
First, if a is equal to one, then he performs an X
operation or in other words, a NOT gate on his qubit B,
and otherwise if a is equal to zero, then he doesn't do that.
And along similar lines,
if b is equal to one, then Bob performs a Z operation
or a Z-gate or a phase flip
also on the qubit b and like
before, if b is equal to zero, then he doesn't do that.
This is all indicated in the figure where we have these controlled-X
and controlled-Z gates where the controls are
the two classical bits.
You don't have to think of these gates as being control gates
if you don't want to, this is just a handy way
to express what we want
in the form of a circuit diagram. The point is that Bob applies
an X-gate to the qubit b if a is equal to one and
then he applies a Z-gate
to the qubit b if B equals one.
And for the sake of convenience later we can write down explicitly
the combined operation that Bob performs on his qubit b,
depending upon the classical
bits that Alice sends.
So that is the teleportation protocol, it's pretty simple really, the
fact that it actually works is a different matter
and although the analysis
isn't that complicated,
you should not feel that you're missing something if you don't immediately see why it works.
That's why we need to
go through an analysis and that's what we will do next.
To analyze the teleportation protocol, we'll work through it one step at a time to see what the states
of the three Qubits are at different points in time.
We're gonna first consider
the case that the top qubit is in the state AlphaZero plus beta one, where alpha and beta
are any complex numbers
that cause this vector
to be a unit vector.
This is the qubit Q that
Alice is trying to transmit, but we don't really care what
it's called at this moment.
A little bit later, we'll
take a look at the situation in which this qubit is
entangled with another system, but this is a good starting
point just to keep things simple
and to see how the analysis
works a little bit more clearly.
If we consider the state of
the three Qubits together here at the start, we see
that this state has the form that you see right here.
The first two Qubits are
in the Phi plus state, the third qubit is the top one
according to the convention
for ordering Qubits that I
described in the previous lesson, and so we take the tensor product to get the state of the
three Qubits together.
We can expand this expression
by first substituting the definition of the Phi plus state and then computing the tensor product
and we get the state
that you see right here.
It's not always the best
strategy by the way, to completely expand
out a vector like this, it's generally a good idea to wait until
you have a good reason to do this.
But here we do have a reason, which is that we would
like to compute the action of this controlled NOT gate and by writing in the state in this form,
we can very easily do that.
And in particular, this is
the state of the three Qubits after the controlled NOT gate is applied.
The third qubit is the control qubit because that's the one that's
on top by our convention, and the second qubit,
which is the middle one,
is the target, so we just
operate on the cats accordingly, if the third bit is a
zero, nothing happens,
and if the third bit is a one,
then we flip the second bit.
Then we perform the Hadamard
gate on the third qubit, we can write the resulting
vector like you can see
right here substituting the
plus and the minus state for the zero and the one state.
And if we wanna have enough
room to expend this one out, we're gonna need to shrink
it down a little bit and now, by substituting the
plus and the minus states
with their definitions,
bringing the square root of two into the denominator, we get the state that you see right here.
And by expending that one out, we get the state that you see right here.
So, that is the state of the three Qubits after Alice performs her two operations.
Alice then measures
and if we wanna analyze the measurements, what we do is to isolate the standard basis vectors
for the systems being measured
just like we talked about in lesson two, and if we do that in this particular case, this is what we obtain.
And if you look at that
expression for a moment, it might seem a little bit peculiar because now it looks like the first qubit,
which is the bottom qubit
somehow depends upon alpha and beta, even though at
this point there hasn't been any communication across the dotted line,
but that's just an illusion. Remember that scalar float
freely through tensor products, so there's really no sense
in which alpha and beta
are associated with the first qubit.
All we've really done
here is to use parentheses in accordance with the
multilinearity of tensor products.
Anyway, that's the form that we need to see what the measurement does, and we can see one
interesting thing right away
and that is that the probabilities of the four possible measurement outcomes are always uniform.
The probability to measure each
pair of measurement outcomes is one quarter, so, in particular,
there's no dependence
whatsoever on alpha and beta.
We can see that in each case by computing the Euclidean norm squared of
whatever vector is tensored to the standard basis
vector that we isolated,
and in each case we have a one quarter which we get by squaring one half times the absolute value squared of alpha
plus the absolute value
squared of beta, which is one, and so we get one quarter in each case.
It's quite important in
fact that the probabilities of these different outcomes don't depend in any way on the qubit that
Alice wants to transmit.
We couldn't have that an arbitrary state comes in up here and comes out down here and yet a measurement revealed
information about that state.
If you wanna gain information about an arbitrary quantum state, you're gonna have to disturb
that state in general.
Here's a table that describes not only the probabilities
of the different outcomes, but also the state of
the three Qubits together
conditioned on each possible
measurement outcome.
We get this by normalizing the vectors tensored to the different
standard basis states, but that's easy in this case,
we just eliminate the factor of one half to get a unit vector.
So, what we have immediately
after Alice measures is that Alice has two uniform
random bits and that's it.
In particular, she no longer
has the original state and she doesn't have any
information about it, she just has random bits.
Bob's state now does
depend on alpha and beta as well as on the measurement outcomes.
If we imagine momentarily
that Alice hasn't yet sent the measurement outcomes
so that Bob doesn't know what the measurement outcomes are,
then he wouldn't be able
to gain any information about alpha and beta
from measuring his qubit.
These four possibilities
that we have right here are sufficiently scrambled to ensure that no information
about alpha and beta
could ever be gained
through a measurement. That has to be true at an intuitive level because otherwise we'd have
faster than light communication.
Alice certainly can't
transmit information to Bob without sending anything at all, but of course Alice does
send the measurement outcomes
to Bob, so let's expand the table to see what happens when
Bob performs his operations.
In this column right here, we have the different operations that Bob effectively performs for each of the possible
outcomes of the measurements
like we observed before,
and if we go one by one and we apply that
operation to Bob's qubit, which is the first one, B,
we see that we get the same
outcome in all four cases and that outcome is the original state.
So, the original state of the qubit Q has been successfully teleported into B.
If Bob wants to rename his qubit and call it Q at this point, he's certainly welcome to do that, but the point is that now
he holds the original state
that Alice had and of course by necessity, Alice doesn't have it anymore.
Notice also that the e-bit
has effectively been burned up through this process,
teleportation has a cost
and the cost is one e-bit and two classical bits of communication, and when the protocol is
over, the e-bit is gone.
We've now established that
the teleportation protocol works correctly under the assumption that the top qubit is in a quantum state
of the form alpha times cat
zero plus beta times cat one.
But what happens if the
top qubit is entangled with some other system such as
one of our additional Qubits
as we have here on the screen? We might wish to use teleportation
under such circumstances.
Maybe Alice and Bob actually
plan to perform teleportation 100 times so that Alice can transmit
some 100 qubit quantum register
to Bob, one qubit at a time.
Or maybe these additional
Qubits aren't even in Alice's possession at all
and somebody else has them, maybe Alice doesn't even
know that they exist.
The question is, does
teleportation still work even though the qubit being teleported is entangled with another system?
Here, the state of the qubit Q together with the additional
system that we're considering is expressed as you can see right up here
where gamma zero and
gamma one are unit vectors representing quantum states
of this additional system.
We can always write an arbitrary state of the combined system in this way.
We don't actually even
need alpha and beta here, but if we include them,
then we can take gamma zero and gamma one to be unit vectors
and that'll make the
connection to the simpler case we've already considered more transparent.
We can go through a
similar analysis to the one that we already went through, but where we also keep track
of this additional system.
It's a little bit messier because we have the additional system, but
the idea is exactly the same, here's a very quick summary.
This is the initial state, here's the state after
the controlled NOT gate,
and here's the state after
the Hadamard operation.
If we expand these things
out, we can express that state as you can see right here,
that's the state immediately
before Alice's measurements, and if we go through the
possibilities just like before
and we consider what
happens when Bob applies whatever operation he's supposed to apply,
then we find that indeed
the correct state comes out and the protocol works as expected.
In this table by the way, we're using the letter R to
refer to this additional system, and you can see that we're
using a pretty simple trick,
which is to decide that we would rather, at least momentarily, order
the systems as B, R, A, Q
because that's more convenient for writing the states right here.
According to the diagram, the systems should be
ordered as B, A, Q, R,
but as long as we make it clear, we can choose a different
ordering that's more convenient.
In a nutshell, everything that's happening in this analysis is the
same as what happened in the simpler analysis,
but we happen to have
these additional vectors, gamma zero and gamma one
that basically come along for the ride.
We always have gamma zero
when there's a factor of alpha and gamma one when
there's a factor of beta and at the end of the day,
it all works out correctly.
This is actually not at all surprising, we have a physical process that acts like the identity
operation on a qubit
in an arbitrary quantum state, and there's only one
way that that can happen and that is that the operation
is the identity operation.
That's a little bit easier to explain using the general formulation
of quantum information, but the point is that by linearity,
we really didn't need to go through this additional analysis.
Once we know that
teleportation works correctly for a single qubit in isolation, we can conclude that there's
only one possible thing
that can describe what the protocol does, and that is that it implements
the identity operation where a qubit comes in right here
and it comes out right here, effectively acting as a perfect
noiseless quantum channel.
Just a few quick remarks
about teleportation before moving on to the
second example of the lesson, which is superdense coding.
First, I think it's important to clarify that teleportation is not an application of quantum information, it's a protocol
and specifically it's a
protocol for performing quantum communication.
In order for teleportation
as I've described it to be useful, there has to be some reason for performing quantum communication.
Second, it's reasonable to speculate that teleportation could, one
day, become a standard way
to communicate quantum information, and specifically a process known as entanglement distillation
might potentially be used
as a way to communicate Qubits reliably. If Alice and Bob know they're
going to be communicating quantum information or they
have the need to communicate
quantum information, then this process of entanglement distillation
could be used to convert a larger number of noisy e-bits
into a smaller number
of high quality e-bits that could then be used for noiseless or near noiseless teleportation.
The idea is that the process
of entanglement distillation isn't as delicate in some sense, we could accept losses and
if it doesn't work out,
then we could just try it again, whereas the actual Qubits that
we would like to communicate might be considered much more precious.
Of course, this is all speculation, but the point is that it isn't difficult to hypothesize situations
in which teleportation
could be a very practical
way to communicate Qubits.
And the final point
concerning teleportation is that the idea behind teleportation and the way that it works
is quite fundamental
in quantum information and computation, teleportation is really a cornerstone of quantum information
theory and variations
on the idea also often come
up, it's just one example, there are proposals for
implementing different quantum gates
using teleportation, but
where different initial states and measurements are
chosen so that the outcome
is to apply a chosen operation
rather than to communicate.
The next example is superdense coding.
Like quantum teleportation,
superdense coding is a protocol and what it accomplishes is complimentary to teleportation.
Whereas teleportation allows
one qubit to be transmitted using an e-bit and two
classical bits of communication,
superdense coding allows
two classical bits to be transmitted using
an e-bit and one qubit of quantum communication.
So, in short, superdense coding allows for the transmission
of classical information and the reason it's
called superdense coding
is that it allows for two
classical bits of communication to be packed into a single qubit,
but we have to burn an
e-bit to accomplish this.
Here's a more precise
explanation of the setup.
Once again, we have Alice and Bob, where Alice is the sender
and Bob is the receiver, and this time Alice has two classical bits
that she wants to send to Bob.
Alice is able to send Bob a single qubit and Alice and Bob share
an e-bit that they can use to help them to accomplish their task,
which is for Bob to receive
the two classical bits.
Now, there's a sense in which this task may seem less interesting than the task that
teleportation accomplishes,
particularly if we view
that sending Qubits is significantly more
difficult or more challenging than sending classical bits,
which is a pretty reasonable point of view but it is definitely interesting that it's possible to do this.
One reason why it's interesting
is that it is in fact impossible to accomplish
this task of transmitting two classical bits of information
using a single qubit without
making use of the e-bit.
We know this because of a famous theorem known as Holevo's theorem.
Holevo's theorem is
more general than this, and the precise statement
of Holevo's theorem is a bit technical and it
requires some explanation,
but one implication of it
is that you cannot transmit any number of classical
bits of communication using fewer Qubits of
quantum communication alone.
If you want to reliably transmit two classical bits of
information using Qubits and you don't have an
e-bit to make use of,
you're going to have to send to Qubits, so they might as well store the bits that you wanna transmit.
Another reason why superdense
coding is interesting is because of the close
complementary relationship it has to teleportation, and
we'll come back to this
a little bit later. Here is a quantum circuit description of the superdense coding protocol.
For this one, I won't
list out all the steps, but instead we'll just stick with the circuit diagram description.
As you can see, we again
have Alice and Bob, where Alice is on the top
and Bob is on the bottom.
Here is the e-bit that's
initially shared between Alice and Bob, which has
somehow been established prior to the protocol being run.
Alice has two classical bits, A and B, which you can see up here
and through the protocol that the circuit describes,
these two classical bits
will end up in the hands of Bob.
There's just one qubit
that crosses the line between Alice and Bob, and of course there aren't
any classical bits being sent,
it's the transmission of
the two classical bits that's the point of the protocol.
You'll also notice that it has
exactly the same components that are used in teleportation, we have a controlled NOT
gate, a Hadamard gate,
and a Z and an X-gate
controlled by classical bits.
They're arranged differently however, so let's move on to the
analysis to see how it works.
To analyze how superdense coding works, let's start by writing
down the Bell basis, which is very much at the
heart of the analysis.
What we're going to do is
to first take a look at the effect that Alice's actions
have on the Phi plus state, and what we'll see is
that Alice transforms this
Phi plus state into one
of the four Bell states depending on the bits
that she wants to send.
So, let's write down a table so that we can keep
track of what's going on.
First, if A and B are both zero, then neither the Z-gate nor
the X-gate gets applied, so Alice's actions don't do anything,
which is to say that Phi
plus gets mapped to Phi plus.
We can also express that as an equation like you see right here,
nothing happens to Alice's qubit and nothing happens to Bob's qubit
and doing nothing is represented
by the identity matrix.
Now, what happens if A is equal to zero and B is equal to one?
Well, because B is equal to one, we apply the Z-gate and
we don't apply the X-gate because A is equal to zero
and we see that the overall effect is that Alice performs a Z-gate.
Alice is on the right
because she's on the top, although it wouldn't
actually make any difference in this particular
case, the effect is that
the Phi plus date gets
snapped to Phi minus, which you can eyeball
from these expressions if you remember how a Z-gate works works.
So, we can add this one to our table, there are two more cases to go through, if A is equal to one
and B is equal to zero,
then Alice performs an
X-gate which transforms five Phi into Chi plus, and if A is equal to one
and B is equal to one,
then Alice performs Z, then
X and we get Chi minus.
So, our table tells us what happens in the four possible cases and that is that Alice effectively chooses which one
of the four Bell states she
would like to share with Bob, and she has the freedom to choose by acting on her qubit alone
and that's a pretty interesting
aspect of entanglement.
Alice then sends her qubit
to Bob, at this point, Bob holds one of the four Bell states and he just needs to
figure out which one it is
to recover the bits.
And we can check that
indeed a controlled NOT gate followed by a Hadamard gate
as we have in the diagram does the right thing.
I won't go through them in detail, but if you choose to do that, you'll find that the effect is
as you see here in the table.
One way to check that
is simply to compute. Alternatively, we can recognize that we actually already
went through this in reverse
in the previous lesson. In the previous lesson we
had the Hadamard gate first and the controlled NOT gate second
and we saw that that circuit
mapped standard basis states to Bell states with a pesky
minus sign in one of the cases.
When we reverse the order of the gates and we consider the fact
that both of these two gates are their own inverses,
what we get is the inverse,
and so what we have in this
case is the action goes in the opposite direction
and the minus sign can choose whichever
side it wants to be on,
but otherwise, it's where it belongs, and at this point it's
immediate that the measurement reveals the correct values,
the minus sign here doesn't bother us because one appears with
probability one in this case, and that's all there is to the analysis.
In a nutshell, Alice picks a Bell state and Bob figures out which one it is.
Just a couple of brief remarks
about superdense coding before we move on; first, we should acknowledge
that superdense coding
is probably not likely
to be useful or practical in any sense as a means to
transmit classical information.
Classical communication
is very inexpensive and physically sending Qubits is challenging to say the least,
and so long as that's the case, we wouldn't expect any
practical advantage at all to come from superdense coding.
But just because it isn't
likely to be practical doesn't mean that superdense
coding is not interesting.
It's very interesting in fact, for one, the underlying idea is
really quite fundamental,
and when I refer to the underlying idea, I mean the idea that if Alice
shares a Bell state with Bob,
then she can choose to change that state to any other Bell state that
she chooses all by herself, she doesn't need Bob's
help at all to do that.
This is a specific example
that concerns the Bell states, but there's a more general underlying idea that concerns the freedom that one player
has to transform an entangled state that's shared with another player, and understanding exactly
what that freedom is
is an important step in understanding quantum information and we'll see exactly how to describe that freedom in simple
and elegant terms In the
third unit of the series.
Superdense coding also
provides a concrete example of what you can do with entanglement, which is to allow two classical
bits to be transmitted
by sending a single qubit. As I already mentioned, this
is provably not possible by Holevo's theorem without entanglement.
We can also consider teleportation and superdense coding together, and we see that they
establish an equivalence
between one qubit of quantum communication and two bits of classical communication.
As long as you're willing
to spend one e-bit, you can effectively
convert one to the other.
Teleportation allows for the
communication of one qubit using two classical bits of communication and superdense coding goes the other way
and allows two classical
bits of communication using one qubit of quantum communication.
Without spending the e-bit, however, you cannot transform
either one into the other, it's entanglement that
makes this possible.
The third and final example
that we'll cover in this lesson is not a protocol but a
game known as the CHSH game.
When we talk about a game in this context, we're not talking about something that's meant to be
played for fun or sport,
but rather a mathematical abstraction in the sense of game theory for instance.
Mathematical abstractions of games are very commonly studied in
economics and computer science, for instance, and there's
quite a lot of value
to be found in the abstraction, so games are not all fun
in games as it turns out,
although it is fun to think about them.
In this particular case, what we have is essentially
a thought experiment that can be described in a
pretty intuitive way as a game.
The letters CHSH refer to the authors, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, and Richard Holt of a 1969
paper where the example
was first described. They didn't describe
it as a game, in fact, and it's pretty common
to refer to this example
not as the CHSH game, but
rather as the CHSH inequality.
For a computer scientist like me, however, it's just very natural
to describe it as a game.
I've already suggested that
mathematical abstractions of games are both important and useful and there are many different
categories of games
that can be considered. The CHSH game is an
example of a class of games called non-local games.
Here's the setup in general
for a non-local game.
We have two players, Alice and Bob, who cooperate as a team, so they either win together
or they lose together.
This means that they have no
incentive to act selfishly, so it's essentially the opposite
extreme to zero sum games,
which are purely competitive, here the game is purely cooperative.
There's a third entity called the referee.
The referee isn't a player in the game, but rather the referee
runs the game, and in fact, you can think about the specification
of a particular instance
of a non-local game and the specification of a
referee as being equivalent.
There's a critically important constraint that's placed on Alice and Bob, which is that once the game starts, they're forbidden from
communicating with one another.
They can agree beforehand on
whatever strategy they choose, but no communication
is allowed between them during the game itself.
If you like, you can imagine
the game taking place in a secure facility of some sort as if the referee is playing
the role of a detective
and Alice and Bob are suspects located in different
rooms in a police station, but another way of
thinking about the setup
is that Alice and Bob are
separated by a vast distance and communication is prohibited because the speed of light
doesn't allow for communication
to happen quickly enough. If Alice tries to send a
message to Bob for instance, the game will be over by
the time Bob receives it.
The way a non-local game
works is that first, the referee asks both
Alice and Bob a question.
Alice's question is labeled X and Bob's question is labeled Y.
In general, you can think about X and Y as being classical states
from whatever classical states that you like and in the
specific case of the CHSH game,
X and Y are bits.
Alice and Bob must then provide answers, Alice's answer is labeled A,
and Bob's answer is labeled B,
and again, these answers can be viewed as classical states in general and like the questions, they
will be bits in the CHSH game.
At this point, the
referee makes a decision, Alice and Bob either win or they lose depending on whether or not
the pair of answers A, B
is deemed correct for the
pair of questions X, Y that the referee asked, and I'll say a little bit more
about this in just a moment.
First, let's take a
closer look at the referee to understand what it is
that's potentially challenging for Alice and Bob in a non-local game.
And what makes a non-local
game potentially challenging is that the referee can use randomness to choose the questions X and Y.
That means that Alice
and Bob have uncertainty, they don't know ahead of time what question they're going to be asked, and perhaps more importantly,
they don't know what question
the other one received and it's that uncertainty
together with the fact that they can't communicate
that presents the challenge.
So, it's similar to the situation where a detective
interrogates two suspects in different rooms, if
the suspects don't know
what questions the other one is asked, it's much harder if they're guilty to keep their story straight.
Now, I mentioned a short
time ago that the referee makes a determination
that Alice and and Bob have either answered
correctly or incorrectly
depending upon the questions
that they were asked.
It's assumed that this
determination is made according to some fixed
rule and you can consider any rule that you want,
but whatever it is,
it is assumed that Alice
and Bob know the rule, so at least they have a fighting
chance to answer correctly.
We'll take a look at the
rule for the CHSH game in a moment, but we could
consider a different rule and we would have a different
example of a non-local game.
Some non-local games are interesting and in fact some are quite fascinating in mysterious to this day and
some aren't so interesting,
that's just the nature of
the non-local game model.
Anyway, these are the two different things that are needed to describe a referee; how exactly are the questions chosen
and which answer pairs are correct for each possible question pair.
If we have a description
of those two things, then we have a description for the referee and that effectively describes
an instance of a non-local game.
Now let's take a look at
the CHSH game specifically.
The way that the game is
defined or, equivalently, how the referee is defined is as follows;
first, as I've already mentioned, the questions and answers are all bits, so the referee sends a bit X
to Alice and a bit Y to Bob,
and they each respond with a bit. Alice responds with A
and Bob responds with B.
The way the referee chooses
which questions to ask is simple, he chooses
them uniformly at random,
so, the pair of questions X, Y is equally likely to be anyone
of the four possibilities, zero, zero, zero, one,
one, zero, and one, one.
Finally, the rule that
determines which answers win and which answers lose is
that a pair of answers A, B is correct for the pair of questions X, Y
if and only if the exclusive or of A and B is equal to the logical and of X and Y.
That may be a little bit easier to digest if we express those conditions
in the form of a table as you see right here.
In the first column, we have the four possible question pairs, and in the second column we
have the conditions on A and B
that are required for
Alice and Bob to win.
In the first three cases,
the and of A and Y is zero, so the exclusive or must be equal to zero
in order for them to win,
and that's the same thing as saying that A and B must be equal because A and B are bits,
and the fourth case,
the and of X and Y is equal
to one and so the exclusive or of A and B must be equal to one in order for Alice and Bob to win
and that's the same thing
as saying that A and B must be different.
So, that's the CHSH game, and now we can think about
different possible strategies for Alice and Bob and how
well they can do in this game.
Let's start by thinking about
deterministic strategies where Alice's answer A is a
function of the question X that she receives, and
likewise, Bob's answer B
is a function of the
question Y that he receives.
And as it turns out, no
deterministic strategy can possibly win every time.
One way to reason that is
simply to go one by one through all of the possible
deterministic strategies and to check that every one of them loses
for at least one of the four
possible question pairs.
Alice and Bob, each have
four possible functions to choose from, we saw those
four functions in lesson one, so there are 16 possibilities
to check overall.
Another way to see that is to
think about the equations here on the screen, we're thinking
about deterministic strategies
where A and B are functions
of X and Y respectively.
So for example, A of zero
represents Alice's answer when her question X is equal to zero and a of one represents Alice's answer
when her question X is equal to one.
These are the four equations
that have to be true in order for the winning
conditions to be met in each of the four cases.
For example, if X is equal to
zero and Y is equal to zero, then the exclusive or of A
and B must be equal to zero,
whereas in the case that X is equal to one and Y is equal to one, the
exclusive or of A and B must be equal to one.
One way we can see that
there's no way to choose the functions A and B so that
these equations are all true, is simply to take the exclusive
or of all of the equations.
The exclusive or of any
binary value with itself is equal to zero, and so it follows that the exclusive or
of the left-hand sides
is equal to zero, that's
because we have two instances of a zero, two instances of a one,
two instances of B zero
and two instances of B one.
So, xing them all together
gives us the final answer of zero, but if we take the exclusive or of the right hand sides of the equations,
we get one not zero. So the four equations
can't possibly all be true, at least one of them has to be wrong
and that will lead to a
loss for Alice and Bob in at least one of the four cases.
And so it follows because the referee chooses the questions
uniformly that the probability for Alice and Bob to win
using a deterministic strategy
is at most three quarters or 75%.
The fact that Alice and and Bob can win with probability three quarters is quite easy to see
actually, if Alice and and Bob both answer zero all
the time, for instance,
they'll be correct three
out of the four times.
So Alice and Bob can't do
any better than winning 75% of the time using a
deterministic strategy.
But what about a probabilistic strategy?
Well, it turns out that using
a probabilistic strategy can't help them at all, that's because every
probabilistic strategy
can alternatively be viewed
as a random selection of a deterministic strategy just like probabilistic
operations can be viewed
as random selections of
deterministic operations, as we saw in the first lesson.
The average is never
larger than the maximum, so it follows that a
probabilistic strategy doesn't offer any advantage
in terms of winning
over a deterministic strategy. This even includes the possibility that Alice and Bob's random
choices are correlated.
So, the bottom line is that winning with probability three quarters is the best that Alice
and Bob can possibly do using any classical strategy,
whether it's deterministic
or probabilistic.
The natural question to ask at this point is whether Alice and Bob can do any better using a quantum strategy,
and in particular
if they share an entangled quantum state which they could have repaired
prior to playing the game, can that help them?
The answer is yes, it can, and that is the point of the example and that's why it's so interesting.
So let's see exactly how
Alice and Bob can do better in this game using entanglement.
The first thing we need to do is to define a quantum state vector Chi
theta for each angle theta, as you can see here on the screen.
So, Chi theta is equal to
cosine theta times cat zero plus sine theta times cat
one, and here by the way,
we're thinking about
angles in terms of radians.
So for example, here's the vector we get when theta is equal to pi over
four, which is 45 degrees.
Cosine of pi over four
and sine of pi over four are both equal to one over
the square root of two, so this is just another
name for the plus state.
Here's another example when theta is equal to three times pi over eight, and in case you don't
happen to know the sine
and cosine of three times pi over eight off the top of your head,
here's a table of the sines and the cosines that we're
actually going to need
throughout this example
and includes the ones that we need for this particular vector.
Now, if we wanna take the inner product between any two of these vectors
for angles, alpha and beta let's say, it's
straightforward to do that.
We only have real number
entries in these vectors so there are no complex
conjugates to worry about and we obtain the product of the cosines
plus the product of the the sines, and we can use one of the
so-called angle addition formulas
to simplify that, it's the
cosign of the difference between the angles and
because the cosine function
is symmetric around zero,
it doesn't actually matter which order we take them in.
If you don't have these sorts
of trigonometric identities committed to memory, by
the way, you're not alone, but you don't have to remember them,
you can just look them up. This one does make sense
though when you think about the geometric interpretation
of the inner product
between real unit vectors as the cosine of the angle between them.
If we compute the inner
product of the tensor product of any two of these vectors
with the Phi plus state, we get a similar looking expression
except that there's a squared
of two in the denominator.
This is the first time
that the Phi plus state has appeared in the context
of this example by the way, and we'll see exactly why we're interested
in this particular inner product shortly, but for the moment let's
just observe that we obtain the same expression that we had
for the inner product divided
by the square root of two and so we can simplify as before.
Next, we'll define a
unitary matrix, U theta, for each angle theta
like you see right here,
it's not difficult to
check that this is indeed a unitary matrix.
The key thing we need to
recognize is that the vectors si theta is orthogonal to
the vector si theta plus pi over two, and that makes sense
because if we rotate by pi over two, which is 90 degrees, we
get an orthogonal vector.
If we then multiply U
theta to U theta dagger, we get the identity matrix.
Intuitively speaking,
what this matrix does as an operation is to
map si theta to cat zero and si theta plus pi two to cat one.
At this point, we have
everything that we need to describe Alice and Bob's strategy.
First, just like we had for teleportation and superdense coding, Alice and Bob will start out by sharing an e-bit.
Alice holds a qubit A,
bob holds a qubit B, and together the two Qubits
are in the Phi plus state.
Alice's actions are as follows; she looks at the bit X that
she receives from the referee,
and if X is equal to zero,
she performs U zero on A, which happens to be the
same thing as doing nothing because U zero is the identity matrix,
effects is equal to one on the other hand, she applies U pi over four to A.
After she applies one
of the two operations, she measures A using a
standard basis measurement and sends whatever result
she gets to the referee.
Bob does something very similar, his qubit is called B of course, and he receives Y from the
referee as opposed to X
but the key difference is
that he uses different angles for his unitary operations.
If Y is equal to zero, he
applies U pi over eight, and if Y is equaled one, he applies u negative pi over eight.
And we'll see why these choices of angles are good choices shortly,
it's not at all obvious.
And here is a circuit diagram
that expresses this strategy.
Bob is in the top and Alice
is on the bottom this time, here is the e-bit that is coming in
and these are the unitary
gates that Alice and Bob might or might not apply
depending upon what X and Y are.
For this one and this one, we have gates that are being controlled either by the bit X or by the bit Y
and for these two right here, we have what kind of
look like control gates except that the circle isn't filled in.
And what this means is
that if the control bit is set to zero, then the gate is performed and if the control is set to
one, then nothing happens.
So, it's just like an
ordinary control gate except that the roles of zero and one for the control are swapped.
So, effectively, Bob
performs this gate right here if Y is equal to zero, he
performs this gate right here
if Y is equal to one, and similarly, Alice performs this gate right
here if X is equal to zero, and this gate right here,
if X is equal to one.
So, that is Alice and Bob's strategy and now we just need to
figure out how well it works.
For the analysis of the quantum strategy that I just described, we
really only need two things at this point, first, the
unitary matrix U Theta
is as you see right here, and
second we had this formula.
We don't actually even need the definition of the vector si theta anymore, these two equations are all we need.
There are four cases to
consider starting with case one, which is that X equal
zero and Y equals zero.
And if we look back at the strategy, we'll find that in this
case Alice performs U zero on her qubit and Bob performs
U pi over eight on his qubit.
Remember, Alice is on the
bottom and Bob is on the top, so the state that they
obtain looks like this.
And by expanding that out
according to the definition of U theta, we get this
expression you see right here.
We don't need to expand
that out any further because we have the other
formula to help us out.
And if we apply that formula
for each of the four terms, what we get is this.
At this point Alice and Bob both measure and here's a table that
explains the distribution of the outcomes.
We take the absolute value
squared of the coefficients to get the probabilities, which happens to be the
squares of the coefficients
because the coefficients are
all real numbers in this case.
If we make use of the
sine and cosine values from earlier in the lesson
along with some symmetries, we can express these probabilities
as we have right here
in the last column.
Now, what we really care
about is the probability that they win, and remember that, in the case that X and Y are both zero,
they win if A and B are equal and they lose if A and B are not equal.
If we calculate those probabilities, we find that the probability
that A and B are equal is the sum of this number and this number,
which is equal to two plus
root two all over four, which is about 85%.
The probability that A and B are not equal is two minus root two all over four, which is naturally one minus the quantity
that we just calculated, so
they win with probability about 85% in this case.
There are three more cases to consider, but they're all very similar to this one,
in the case that X equals
zero and Y equals one, Bob applies U negative pi over eight rather than U pi over eight,
the values in the
formulas change somewhat, but we end up with exactly
the same probabilities that we had in the previous case.
When X equals zero and Y equals one, Alice and Bob still win
when A and B are equal and so we have exactly the
same winning probability
as before.
In the third case, when X is equal to one and Y is equal to zero, we
have a similar situation, the angles are different,
but they have exactly
the same relationship to
one another, and in fact, we do get exactly the
same vector that we got in the previous case.
So the probabilities are the same and so is the winning probability.
The last case is a little bit
different as we might expect because the winning condition
is different in this case.
When X and Y are both equal to one, Alice and Bob win when
A and B are different.
The basic method is the same, although the angles are different, this time, we get this vector right here
and you can check that by going through the required subtractions.
The probabilities do change finally, and if we look up the values that we need, we see that the probabilities
have effectively
swapped positions from before, so this time it's the probability
that A is not equal to B, that is the larger of the two,
but that's good because in this case, Alice and Bob win when
A and B are not equal.
So once again, they win with
probability approximately 85%.
Given that they win in every
case with the same probability, which is two plus root two
all over four or about 85%,
that's the probability
that they win overall.
That's better than any classical strategy can do for this game, and that's
what makes it interesting.
This happens to be the
optimal winning probability for any quantum strategy, you
can't do any better than this using any entangled state.
That fact is known Tsirelson inequality, it's named named for Boris
Tsirelson who first proved it, and to my knowledge was
one of the first people
to describe this example as a game. In case the analysis
that we just went through seems a little bit mysterious,
it's possible to think
about it geometrically, which might be helpful to
give you a better sense for the choice of the angles.
Specifically, if we use the
formula that you see right here, which we can easily deduce
from the expressions
we already found for the
inner products involved, then we can alternatively
express the probabilities of the different possible
measurement outcomes
in the four cases as follows; first, if X, Y equals zero, zero, then these are the probabilities
of the various measurement outcomes, and you have to either think back or look back at the analysis
that we just went through to conclude that using our formula.
Over here, we can see the
different state vectors drawn as they were before, and the color coding here
is that blue corresponds
to the outcome zero and red
corresponds to the outcome one.
You can see that the angle
between the blue vectors and the angle between the red
vectors is relatively small,
it's pi over eight in both cases, so the cosine is relatively large, and that means that the
probability that the two outcomes
are equal is relatively large.
In the case that X, Y equals zero, one, it's a similar situation, the
angles between the vectors having the same color is small,
so the probability of
equal outcomes is again, relatively large.
The third case is similar, and in the fourth case
when X, Y equals one, one, something interesting happens,
this time, just by the way,
these vectors have been chosen, we see that the angles between
vectors having the same color
are relatively large, and specifically the angles are three times
pi over eight in both cases.
This means that the probability
that the measurement outcomes is equal is relatively small, but this is the one case
in which Alice and Bob win
when their answers disagree,
so it's what we want.
Once again, here are the vectors: when X, Y equals zero, zero,
when Xx, Y equals zero, one,
when X, Y equals one, zero,
and when X, Y equals one, one.
And perhaps this geometric
picture is helpful in building some intuition
for how this strategy works
and why these various angles were chosen in the way that they were.
To finish off the lesson, I'll make a few brief
remarks about the CHSH game.
First, as I've already mentioned, this example isn't always
described as a game.
In the physics community, for instance, it's more common that
the example is described simply as an experiment rather than a game
and Alice and Bob are
viewed as being detectors rather than players.
The basic idea of an experiment like this where entanglement leads
to statistical results that are inconsistent with
any classical description
or more generally any
theory based on so-called local hidden variables,
is due to John Bell, the namesake of the Bell states,
and so people often refer
to experiments of this sort as Bell tests.
Sometimes people also
refer to Bell's theorem, which can be formulated in different ways, but it basically says
that quantum mechanics
is not compatible with so-called local hidden variable theories.
The CHSH game or inequality is essentially a very nice and clean
example of a Bell test,
and you can think about
this example as a proof or a demonstration of Bell's theorem.
The second remark is that the CHSH game offers us one way to experimentally test that the theory of quantum information
is an accurate theory. We can actually set up experiments that implement the CHSH game,
including the sort of
strategy based on entanglement that I had just described, and
see if it works, and it does.
This provides us with a
high degree of confidence that entanglement is real, and unlike the perhaps
vague or poetic ways
that we try to come up with
to explain entanglement, the CHSH game or experiment
gives us a concrete
and testable way to observe entanglement.
If that sounds important,
it's because it is, and the 2022 Nobel Prize
in physics acknowledges exactly this.
The prize was awarded to
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, who is the C in CHSH, and Anton Zeilinger
for experiments with entangled photons that established the violation
of Bell inequalities, or in other words, that
showed that quantum strategies
of the sort that I described actually work and outperform classical strategies.
And if you're interested in
learning more about this, I encourage you to check out
the video on Bells Theorem by my colleague Olivia Lanes,
right here on the Qiskit YouTube channel.
And finally, the topic of
non-local games more generally is truly fascinating, and it's
an active area of research
that brings together
physics, computer science, and pure mathematics and there are still many
interesting questions
about non-local games that
remain unanswered to this day.
And that is the end of lesson four, as well as the end of
unit one of the series on the Basics of Quantum Information.
The first lesson explained
how quantum information works for single systems in isolation, and the second lesson explained
how quantum information
works for multiple systems,
which pretty naturally emerges from how it works for single systems.
The third lesson introduced
the quantum circuit model of computation, and in the fourth lesson, we took a look at three important examples
that illustrate things we
can do with entanglement.
Along the way, we saw some very important mathematical concepts,
including tensor products and inner products, and we observed
some fundamental limitations
of quantum information.
I hope you'll join me for
the next unit of the series, which will be on quantum algorithms, where we'll focus on the question
of what computational advantages
quantum information offers.
Goodbye until then.